problème là et elle tient pas dans les
services aux autistes en fait elle tient
dans l'amélioration des services pour
les personnes qui ne sont pas parce que
c' est actuellement c'est l'énorme
différence de qualité et de quantité de
services entre ce qu'on obtient quand on
est autiste et ce qu'on obtient quand on
l'est pas est bien actuellement tout le
système va favoriser un conte tonnes une
étiquette au prix de mentir un petit peu
pour obtenir les services près
d'entrevue à 24,67 semaine entrevue qui
fait beaucoup réagir c'est cette vaste
étude en fait sur l'autisme qui a été
publié au cours des derniers jours dans
laquelle le psychiatre laurent mothron
vous venez d'entendre ce inquiet de la
façon dont on pose le diagnostic
d'autisme avec des critères qui
donnerait lieu à du surdiagnostic à son
avis avec la méta-analyse qu'il a
publiés et donc à de nombreux faux
diagnostics et les impacts serait très
important dans les écoles on va aller
voir ce qu'en pense et j'ai de royer
psychologue et spécialiste des enfants
en difficulté en milieu scolaire sur why
et bonjour je me trouve avec la vaste
expérience que vous avez pour les
enfants en difficulté dans les classes
à l'aube de la rentrée scolaire comment
vous réagissez aux conclusions de
l'étude
monsieur mothron 10 pour les jeunes a
qu'un trouble du spectre de l'autisme
est vrai pour l'ensemble des jeunes en
difficulté au québec système que d'un
système catégoriel de donner une forme
de diagnostic une identification de code
12 enfants
et quand de l'importante pays on une
augmentation de 200% sulem salut doubler
le nombre d'élèves en difficulté de 2001
2002 jusqu'à 2016 et on voir les
troubles déficitaires de l'attention
avec hyperactivité enveloppement
assemble des jeunes qui présentent une
forme de handicap et en tant que le tdah
trouble déficitaire de l'attention et
d'hyperactivité donc souligner pour
l'autisme est vrai pour rendre cette
problématique là important de continuer
à utiliser les codes ou les diagnostics
psychiatriques pour offrir les services
éducatifs et des jeunes en milieu
scolaire et ça donc cette augmentation
de diagnostic ou d'étiquettes parfois on
appelle ça comme ça vous associez ça
vous aussi à la façon dont on octroie
les services aux élèves dans les écoles
que vous nous expliquer comment ça
fonctionne les services aux élèves
je confirme un niveau il ya un groupe de
jeunes qui ont dit les jeunes entrent
évidemment handicapés et quand les
jeunes autistes le parce que je n'avais
l'action globale il ya un financement
spécifique par rapport à des jeunes qui
ont ce type de diagnostic le 5 et
d'alors - l'ailé
là tu lances dans le spécialiser ou que
ses élèves que leurs comptes pour plus
qu'un élève si longtemps classe
ordinaire donc le sel de d'étiquettes ou
de codes jour le financement mais joue
aussi la gestion de la convention
collective des enseignants
si moi j'ai un vestige est un trouble du
spectre de l'autisme jeu m'avait compté
pour plus fun et dépendances
et ça c'est il ya un aspect qui
conduisait sa part tient pas en avril
aux de manière évidente depuis quelques
années c'est que l'on me manquait
beaucoup mais ça ne garantit pas des
services de qualité par rapport à ces
jeunes hommes et une pression mal pour
sortir le diagnostic de tdr jeu pour
avoir plus de temps dans mes examens au
secondaire comme une pression aussi pour
sortir un diagnostic d'autisme de dôme
ou similaire pour un groupe
qu'est ce que je comprends qu'un enfant
qui a des besoins particuliers mais
qu'il n'a pas nécessairement de
diagnostic ne peut pas recevoir de
services tant qu'il n'en a pas un et
donc signé par un médecin alors qu'on
parle de psychologues orthopédagogues
orthophonistes exact où s'est pas
activée le médecin par un baobab une
professionnelle l'extravagant secteur
prenez l'exemple des jeunes en
difficulté comportement il avait déjà un
cocktail qui aurait besoin d'avoir des
titres de services très très tôt
maternelle 4 en maternelle 5 1 mais
souvent ça va être liés ou à ceux ci à
une forme de diagnostic ou de formes
d'évaluation de la rémission de l'ordre
des psychologues du québec du comité
québécois
les jeunes en difficulté même de ce
qu'ils touchent entre autre que le fils
cadet le chatellier droit alors que son
goût de famille des individus ont
constaté objectivement qu'il faut y
aller davantage sur une évaluation
individualisé des services non
déterminée par un diagnostic pour est
capable d'adapter les services sur
mesure et des jeunes d'intervenir le
plus tôt possible
qu'est ce que la sens bien mais c'est
royer est ce que vous estimez que c'est
urgent de revoir la façon dont ça se
passe au québec c'est l'année qui va
falloir leur voix par une carriole la
négociation entre aux dépens du
collectif des enseignants
25 ans photo dans une situation
présentant que soit le fils des
professionnels office de l'ordre dès
lors de psychologues d'autres types
d'organismes on réclame une révision de
la politique des services aux élèves en
difficulté comet en vingt ans et qui ont
besoin d'être visées contenues l'eau
bleue du problème ou des diagnostics des
problèmes de diagnostic on a l'idée
assez que utiliser des diagnostics ce
qui a trait aux reflets les services
éducatifs ne tient pas la route
présentement ça mène les opérations et
les mains des membres du service par
rapport à sa plage
alors est ce que c'est une situation qui
risque d'empirer avec l'arrivée des
centaines de classes ce matin dès 4 ans
à votre avis
je fais que non ce que je veux ce que je
cache web comme certain nombre de
personnes soit il dit c'est de d'éviter
d'avoir à diagnostiquer ou à donner
l'école des enfants 4 1
on est en mesure d'offrir des services
précoce pour prévenir certaines
difficultés
et ça ça va devenir très très important
donc selon moi ça devrait être un objet
de réflexion très important dès cette
année d'éviter de colis ou de donner
justement une éthique et d'aider à 24
ans sachant que les diagnostics sont
très flottant on n'est jamais sûr de
rien dans la majorité des cas et dirais
de manière davantage inclusive où j'ai
la classe en classe de maternelle 4 ans
je reçois des services ou de l'aele
parce que juste certains types de
difficultés mais j'ai pas besoin d'avoir
un diagnostic les recevoir oui je pose
la question en fait parce que vous avez
été très très proche de la création dès
maintenant quatre ans au québec auprès
du ministre de l'éducation
on l'a vu au cours des derniers jours la
commission parlementaire là c'est pas
facile il ya beaucoup d'opposition vous
restez toujours aussi convaincu que
c'est la bonne chose à faire c'est un
progrès important le système scolaire
québécois d'ajouter un niveau un nouveau
niveau 1 ou 2 degrés sous un buick la
maternelle 4 ans qui va faire une
différence importante pour avoir la
réussite scolaire il était totalement
impensable que moi
la pâte quatre ans j'ai accès en
maternelle 80 parce que mon code postal
est un code postal de milieux
défavorisés où j'ai accès à internet
quatre ans parce que je marie ou privé
je vais quatre cinq six mille dollars
par an développe tenir la majorité des
jeunes en difficulté ou la majorité les
jeunes vulnérables ne vivent pas en
milieu défavorisé
donc c'était j'étais bien été relevé un
développement important système éducatif
que d'ajouter ce niveau là au choix les
parents comblés d'ailleurs maintenant
des 56 besoin comme son parlementaire
donc qu'il va se terminer au cours des
prochaines journées
egide royer merci d'avoir été avec nous
et bien sûr aux vagues avait ça en tête
la vos commentaires concernant la façon
de revoir les services octroyés aux
enfants et dans les écoles merci et
bonne journée